this is what would happen if you were  swallowed by an anaconda  these snakes can grow up to 9 meters in  length and weigh up to 225 kilograms and  if given the right opportunity they  could easily swallow you at first the  anaconda would widen his jaw and cover  you in saliva to moisten you this would  make it easier for you to travel down  the snake's gullet you'd move to the  esophagus where the snake's muscles  would push you down into its stomach  in just a couple of days your skin and  bones would be dissolved by the  anaconda's incredibly strong stomach  acid  as you moved through the small intestine  your body would be broken down even more  that's because the snake's pancreas and  liver have even more stomach enzymes to  dissolve you  and after a couple of weeks  you'd eventually be  pooped out by the anaconda so i think  i'll leave these snakes alone because